well on Sunday the Pro Bowl meanwhile is
back in Las Vegas part of the big
football weekend here in town yeah but
you can watch all the action and we're
saying time Candice Charles at
Candice Sherry says we need to wear a
helmet if we're anywhere near you while
you're playing golf
[Music]
probably right yeah I can come down here
and probably do a little bit better all
while watching the big game really and
watching the Pro Bowl and watching the
tribal they have lots of TVs here it's a
great Vibe and I have mayor Lavon care
with me from Topgolf thank you so much
for joining us now I've told people it's
a great life but you got to tell us a
little bit more about why people should
come down here I mean there's food
there's drinks there's giant screens and
there's some golf so you could play well
I mean the game's on everywhere here
yeah and I know a lot of people do come
out and come to do the experience tell
us a little bit about how the golfing
works because I'm going to be trying a
little bit right now yeah I mean you've
been practicing all morning thank you
thank you getting there yes so there's
RFID chips in each of the golf balls so
as the golf ball comes out of this
little pocket here it reads the RFID
chip inside the golf ball right and it
knows you're playing on the screen so
once you hit it into the target it reads
that and it scores based on those points
all right Mary well I'm gonna try to hit
in the Target we'll see if this happens
thank you thank you and I'm joining by
Lauren again our new morning reporter
you guys say hello all right we've been
practicing we're ready to do this let's
do it all right here we go
Candace Charles on the tee the 18th hole
I almost got it in there yeah
we made it we made it that's teamwork
you guys we got to cover with more
details on our website eight newsnow.com
for now live from Topgolf off of kovo
I'm Candace Charles it is now we'll give
that a mulligan that was a bit of a
mulligan that's fine though I can't John
so I'm terrible thank you appreciate it